[Music]  so there are certain things I think  every guy should know things like how to  cook a great meal how to make a good  cocktail where to go to find a good  haircut how to properly get fitted for a  suit with jen salaams we're pulling from  chefs bartenders fashion icons to put it  all into one succinct source for today's  modern gentleman fellas how are we you  guys want to do for 45 s cocktail we're  talking about earlier this okay so we're  using remedy 1738 fantastics and the  cane syrup some lemon balm bitters I  made it home and then classic angostura  it's fantastically this is a variation  of an old fashioned that I was working  with George a couple weeks ago anything  worth doing is worth doing right even  this moment right now is like a perfect  example of that the perfect cocktail in  the perfect bar with the perfect people  you know this is the right moment and we  did it right jus today  [Music]